and now our next presenter is a very
talented star you loved him and there's
something about Mary you loved him and
meet the parents and you were fine with
him in Mystery Men
here he is Ben Stiller
thank you you know there's an old saying
in Hollywood it's not the length of your
film it's how you use it the nominees
for Best live action short film are by
courier Peter Riegert and Erica
Frederick one day crossing joan Stein
and Christina Lazar Edie
quieto said I want to be Laurie and
gallenberger Sanaa glio a learner and
Colin Campbell a soccer story
uma história the football how long
McLean and the Oscar goes to quiero ser
i want to be florian gallenberger
first Academy Award and
nation for florian gallenberger
good evening I guess there are not so
many great moments in your life and this
is definitely one of the greatest for me
and therefore I want to thank the
wonderful people who made this film with
me some of them are here where are you
and and I want to thank Mexico where we
shot the film for being such a strange
and hard to understand country with so
much magic I want to understand I want
to thank my film school and the film
foundations who financed me
I hope they will also financed me in the
future and I want to thank all of you
for this great honor it's a really great
moment for me thank you very much
you know there's another old saying in
Hollywood don't try to be funny while
introducing the nominees for best
animated short film the nominees for
best animated short are father and
daughter Michael do duck DeWitt the
Perry wig maker Stefan Shepler and
Annette shipler rejected Don Hertzfeld
and the Oscar goes to father and
daughter Michael do dr. Witt
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Michael Guidotti
win
he was an Oscar contender in 1994 for
the month and the fish
I would like to thank my two producers
Claire Jennings from London and William
Tyson from Amsterdam and both for their
dedication and very hard work and I
would like to thank especially my wife
Arielle for for her support Thank You
Academy members this is fantastic